[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here so you remember
the original surface duo the dual screen
foldable android device from microsoft
had a lot of potential and a lot of hype
behind it we were hoping it would be
great
and then it just wasn't really that good
at all disappointingly it had pretty
weak performance the software was very
buggy and uh the camera
was trash but like the one nice thing
about it was it had really nice sleek
thin
hardware and a great hinge
but there was a lot to fix but now one
year later we have
the sequel the shiny new dark colored
sequel the answer to microsoft's
nightmares the surface duo 2.
sweet so this isn't the full review i
haven't had it for very long but i have
some initial impressions on it which are
that
i think that this device and all
microsoft has done to it has revealed
that this idea
may
not really have a great feature it may
be fundamentally flawed
in the way it's used like microsoft went
through and valiantly improved a ton of
stuff about this especially versus the
original they found a lot of flaws they
made them all objectively better
and yet some of that stuff still
also made it worse see pretty much all
the changes microsoft has made are
objectively better than the last one so
there's a bunch of stuff here they have
all new high-end specs inside they've
made the displays bigger and faster with
thinner bezels and they added a set of
real cameras on the back and there is
much better software implementation to
tie it all together but yet this surface
duo has a completely new set of problems
that this surface duo didn't have but
then the cherry on top is this new one
is now uh 14.99 1499
that's actually more expensive than the
first one which started at 13.99 before
it plummeted the whole year it was out i
think it was eventually like 900 off or
something like that so you might think
wow that's a bold move making an even
more expensive surface even when the
first one flopped so hard but
this was also clearly gonna cost more to
make so you might remember when the
first surface duo came out it had
one-year-old slightly out-of-date specs
this one's launching with the highest
end chip it's a snapdragon triple eight
is eight gigs of ram and up to half a
terabyte of storage and they've done a
lot with this new display here so first
of all it's slightly bigger it's 8.3
inches corner to corner now with nearly
the same size footprint because the
bezels are smaller all the way around
especially that top bezel no more flash
needed since the main camera system is
on the back now and this display is also
now brighter up to 800 nits and it is
higher fresh rate now it's a 90 hertz
panel weirdly there is no option to
change refresh rate anywhere in the
display settings like you can't knock it
down to 60hz if you want to but whatever
everything is smoother especially while
scrolling but the the main new thing
here with this display is it curves over
the edges in the middle near the hinge
from both sides so it kind of gives this
sort of subtle waterfall look and the
dual screens now kind of have this
effect of looking closer together
almost like it's one giant folding
screen and this definitely encourages
you to span apps across both displays
more often and yet treat it like one big
display
the only problem with that is when you
do
lots of those important pixels in the
middle of the screen are now just
spilling over that edge into being
unreadable but also some are completely
missing like you can't read whatever's
supposed to be in those middle few
pixels so any pictures or any text that
are supposed to be in the middle of the
screen are now just gone which is beyond
annoying it's a it's a bit of a problem
for any sort of reading and you can
forget about spanning games horizontally
imagine trying to aim something with the
crosshairs missing now it's the surface
duo so horizontal gaming isn't really a
huge thing this is actually a great form
factor for
split gaming like this
emulator games all that sort of stuff
split screen top bottom gaming and
that's actually one of the biggest i've
had a little bit of time to play with
this game passes on this device and it's
a lot of fun but yeah
the
missing text in the middle of the screen
uh
not great but then the other big change
to the hardware as you've already seen
is it has real cameras on the back now
it's got a whole triple camera system a
12 megapixel primary plus a 2x telephoto
and a 16 megapixel ultra wide all
stacked into this camera bump that has
matte rails all the way around the
outsides there's a flash next to it
there's hdr portrait mode optical zoom
like these cameras they're not amazing
but they are way more capable than
before so objectively
if we just ignore the design for a
second that's
better like they've put better cameras
on this phone device but you know
obviously microsoft never really wanted
to bolt cameras to the back and ruin
their like perfectly clean sleek thin
design that's why they didn't do it with
the first one and they got the great
hardware but then that meant to take
pictures of stuff you'd have to flip it
open and use the selfie camera like that
and then this was just a webcam it was
pretty bad so this time yeah there's a
set of real cameras on the back they've
caved and done it and i can confirm
they're all better than the webcam was
so having some optical zoom having the
ability to take decent videos that's all
nice i mean it's a 2x telephoto which
isn't that great but it's something but
now that they've made this change which
a lot of people including me were
wondering if they would do it or not
it turns out that this is now a bit
more annoying to use so obviously with
this mesa sticking out the back you're
now unable to fully open the surface duo
to flat anymore so anytime you use it
with one hand fold it back it's got to
be slightly open like this just a few
millimeters short of going flat which is
enough to be easy to slip your finger in
and like close it quickly but it is not
as comfortable to use it for a while and
hold it like this with one hand now i do
admire that they've shaped this camera
bump to match the exact angle that the
back screen folds over and touches it so
that it lays flush just a neat little
little couple degree adjustment there
it's nice it feels like there's also
magnets in here to hold it against that
camera bump but now as you've noticed
that's covering the cameras which means
anytime you want to take photos you have
to swivel it down because closing it up
covers the camera so now you have to
have it open fully like this every time
you take pictures
i don't know maybe you do the viewfinder
open at the top and then the photos
populating at the bottom
and that's cool enough when it works
maybe that's more fun for some people
for taking pictures but
overall yeah that's it's physically less
convenient especially when you just want
to snap a quick photo real quick so you
can see why this idea even though it's a
really cool idea
feels broken like microsoft found ways
to make this
objectively better especially on paper
than the last one but yet it got
more annoying it got worse to use and i
think fundamentally i was thinking about
all the different ways that they could
maybe
save this maybe they can fix this in
some way maybe making it thicker
maybe
you know filling it in so that the
camera bump isn't a bump what are the
things that they could do
i couldn't come up with any because i
feel like the thing that is flawed about
this is the lack of any
outside display just this passport
design like of course there's a ton of
software optimization that's gone into
making this ui work with two screens and
that's super cool
maybe making it a little bit thicker
would give you some more battery to
power these two screens for longer but
that wouldn't really solve anything you
know i thought a lot about the aspect
ratio
about the layout of everything but even
the layouts better here too now the
power button and fingerprint reader are
combined into one believe it or not it
wasn't on the first one and i really
like the matte black rails and this new
darker color it just feels much more
professional it feels more my type to be
honest
but even in the software the software
was buggy last time on the surface duo
and it is buggy again this time too
mainly i've been having touch
responsiveness issues where it really
doesn't like when i start a swipe action
from off the display like if i swipe up
from the bezel
it constantly doesn't respond when i do
that plus there's all kinds of missed
button presses and momentary complete
lapses of all responsiveness it's still
really bad for a device of this price
and you know i'd say i hope they can fix
it with some software but you know
there's been an issue for a full year
now so i'm not exactly optimistic but
the fundamental flaw is like there's no
outside screen which means there's no
usability when it's closed you have to
open it to do anything so we've seen uh
you know even the moto razer and samsung
z flip 3 have
decently usable outside screens and then
of course the fold 3 just has a whole
smartphone ui basically on the outside
you can use it a whole bunch without
ever even opening it now there's a lot
of foldables that have all these
different ways of using it without
opening it but with this you have to
open it and then unlock it and use it
every time and it sounds like such a
small thing just sounds i feel like i'm
just like complaining and it seems
really petty but when you actually use
it it becomes a pretty big deal and this
also means anytime you fully open it and
fold it over flat you have just straight
display glass now on the outside so if
you were to put it in your pocket like
this or put it down on a table like this
that makes the glass pretty vulnerable
to scratches
and it's also just the the extra layer
of having to open it unfold it
unlock the phone and then get started
with everything even for like the
quickest little thing if you just want
to snap a quick picture or you just take
it out your pocket for a quick phone
call every time that's a huge deal to me
now you can view some quick things like
the time and check your notifications by
actually checking that curved over part
of the display in the middle of the
phone while it's closed which is
more than nothing it is actually super
cool that it curves over so much that
you can actually see it and read it in
there
but you don't really interact with it at
all and that's that's the absolute
minimum in terms of functionality and
also this is one just one more thing but
this is minor if you try to place it
down on a desk like this it works but
with the camera bump now you cannot
place it down on a desk on the other
side or it's annoying i mean you can but
it's very wobbly and annoying so it felt
like an ambidextrous device before now
you always have to remember to get it
right so here's my question to you we've
seen companies go back on things right
like we just we just with apple saw them
release the new macbook pro that we're
all loving because
they went back on a ton of the stuff
that we've hated about the last couple
years of macbook pros and now we're all
over it again and so i wonder if
there should be something considered
with the surface duo like what do you
think should microsoft give up on the
outside screen form factor or should
they do an outside screen or should
surface do i would just stay the way it
is for the people who like it the way it
is and who will pay that price to use
this
as it exists today
i don't know i'm curious let me know in
your thoughts below in the comments
section i'm very curious if anyone has
any other ideas about surface duo but
that's pretty much it
anyway stay tuned to the next video
where we have something that i'm a lot
more excited about
for sure much more positive video
it's techtober there's a lot coming
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace